today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video so we
have some big news from the corona virus
testing vaccine front there are a ton of
corona virus vaccines in development
we've talked about some of them some are
sort of closer to a finished vaccine
than others and one of the prominent
vaccines is the Oxford kovat 19 vaccine
we talked last week maybe it was the
week before about the moderna vaccine
another one of the more advanced
vaccines is the Oxford vaccine and this
month they are going to be moving into
Phase two and three trials which will
encompass a total of about 40,000 people
so 40,000 people 40,000 volunteers are
about to receive the Oxford coronavirus
vaccine which is huge it's going to
provide very important information about
the effectiveness of the vaccine at
preventing coronavirus so just to remind
you sort of of the process safety trials
were done before phase one the question
is does the human body tolerate this
aside from whether it will make you
immune does the body tolerate this
safely are there side effects etc we got
past that with the Oxford vaccine then
we had a phase 1 trial phase 1 trial is
a relatively small group it was done in
April 1904 going to now in phase 2 see
10000 people which will include some
older adults and some kids receive the
vaccine the point of phase 2 is does
the age of the person effect antibody
generation do older adults generate the
same antibodies as younger adults do
children generate the same antibodies
with this vaccine as younger adults then
there will I believe simultaneously be a
phase three trial going on which is
going to again just focus on a narrower
age range of adults but it will be a
test for efficacy with an additional
30,000 individuals at least and then the
question is again we're going to go from
a thousand people to thirty thousand and
see how many of them are generating
antibodies after receiving this vaccine
that phase three will also include a
control group which is a very important
thing so the phase two three trials
combined will include over forty
thousand people we're gonna get very
valuable data from this and it does take
some time with the early trials we've
seen that it can take upwards of forty
days for the body to get to its full
antibody generation after receiving the
vaccination so once you have the
antibodies which can take 40 days 43
days in one study then you need to
follow all of those people and see well
do they get coronavirus does this
actually work to protect them from
corona virus and of course how long does
it provide immunity you could you could
say after three months well it seems
like this vaccine is providing at least
three months of immunity but you need
six months of following those people to
be able to say well it looks like it
provides six months of immunity and
that's something that if there's an
early enough efficacy signal so imagine
that by October they say well it seems
to provide at least five months of
immunity you could potentially get an
emergency use authorization and say hey
if it provides five months of immunity
and it's safe let's start giving it to
health care workers five months is
better than nothing
now could this be sped up at all I've
mentioned challenge trials in the past
typically challenge trials are not done
with a vaccine like this a challenge
trial would be rather than doing phase
three where you
follow people and see if they get
infected at a lower rate than those in
the general population
you can deliberately expose people to
the virus that's what a challenge trial
would be called that could potentially
shorten phase three and more quickly
demonstrate that it generates antibodies
that provide protection it wouldn't tell
you how long they last
maybe they last a year but you need a
year to go by to know that there is a
debate about whether a challenge trial
should be done now outside of this
vaccine if you were interested in
participating in a challenge trial
around coronavirus there are lots of
different kinds going on not necessarily
for this vaccine you can find out about
that at one day soon org that's the
number one day sooner one day sooner dot
org the other question when we're
developing a new vaccine and trying to
figure out if it works is manufacturing
capacity so I've talked about this
before if you wait to start
manufacturing huge amounts of the
vaccine until you have results from a
Phase two three trial it's too late in
the sense that it will take months with
the flu vaccine that starts to be
available don't hold me to this but I
think the flu vaccine in that in the US
starts to be available like August
September typically they start
manufacturing that I believe it's April
roughly six months before or five months
before so what is happening here is that
Oxford is partnering with AstraZeneca
they are now going to start
manufacturing large doses of this
vaccine so that if it does work well
there will potentially be you know a
hundred million doses total by the end
of the year from that batch 30 million
would be for the UK this is the Oxford
vaccine and 80 million would be for the
rest of the world so cautious optimism
is the right approach right now this is
one of the many vaccines that we've
talked about last week we talked about
moderna we hope to have at least a
couple of these both work and be
manufactured in bulk in advance so that
by the end of the year we could at least
hopefully dose several million Americans
with it and if you said I don't know
what's going to happen of course if you
said David you've got a bet what would
you bet is going to happen with the
vaccine my bet would be by the end of
the year there will be millions of
Americans vaccinated now we're a country
of 330 million people so if 3 million
people are vaccinated by December 31
it's both no huge win and it's also not
that unlikely but that's where I would
put my money right now I believe the US
will be in the millions of vaccinations
by the end of the year but it's going to
take longer to really start to approach
what could even remotely be referred to
as herd immunity which for something at
the contagion level of coronavirus is
estimated at about 70% immunity okay I
want to get ahead of what is going to be
a barrage of absolute BS garbage math
this is what I'm calling a garbage math
you were going to be hit left and right
by garbage math over the next few months
and the goal of the garbage math will be
for you to think that Donald Trump
deserves to be re-elected and we've
already been starting to see some of
what I'm calling garbage math with
coronavirus for a while so for example
when Trump ist's talk about the total
number of tests that have been done in
the United States that's garbage math it
doesn't tell us very much tests per day
are what matter tests per capita or what
matter we're four months into this thing
right the cumulative number of tests
that have been done tell us very very
little
another example over the last couple of
months we've seen such economic
destruction that it now opens the door
to wild meaningless claims about growth
rates in certain industries which are
already being touted as huge victories
now I want to give you a really specific
example there's been this headline
floating around air travel surges air
travel and bookings surged a hundred and
twenty percent the New York Times
actually wrote about this when this
started being touted so understand when
coronavirus hit air travel dropped by
one estimate 96 percent so when you say
air travel surges a hundred and twenty
percent it has surged
hundred and twenty percent are roughly
doubled from almost zero okay so
imagining that air travel is going well
completely ignores just basic math let's
look at some numbers if you start with
what would be 100 percent right like
full air travel and you then experience
a 96 percent decrease to air travel you
end up with 4 percent of the air travel
you started with you start with
something you take away 96 percent
you're left with 4 percent if you then
increase air travel by a hundred and 20
percent air travel is still down 91
percent from where it was this is just a
common function of how percentages and
growth rates work if you lose 50 percent
of something you need to gain 100
percent to get back to where you were if
I have $100 in stock and that stock
loses 50% of its value my hundred
dollars is now worth $50 to get back to
$100 I need that 50 bucks to increase
100 percent and this is the crux of a
ton of the disinformation propaganda
propaganda garbage math that you are
going to be hit with over the next few
months as the recovery hopefully starts
to happen depending on how deadly
coronavirus remains and how bad wave 2
is you are going to see a lot of the
stuff I'll give you some other examples
jobs have so imploded that they will
start using job growth numbers that will
be meaningless because of the base
numbers that are being used understand
that we lost more than 20% of our
workforce so far we might recover 5% of
the current workforce and they will say
hey we're already a quarter of the way
back that's not how growth rates work if
you lose 20% of the workforce and then
you gain back 5% of that reduced number
you're only gaining 19% of what you lost
not twenty five so understand how these
growth rates work the one that will
really be weaponized is probably going
to be GDP we in all likelihood are going
to see historic GD
P lost numbers for the second quarter in
the United States we're not going to get
those numbers until sometime in August
most likely so normally the numbers
would be for example like o GD P and Q 2
went up point 5 percent usually you
annualize that so 0.5 percent over 4
quarters would be like on track for 2
percent GDP growth for the year ok the
decline in the second quarter is going
to be massive it could be 10 percent
could be 12 percent could be 25 percent
imagine it's 15 percent if you annualize
that 15 percent one quarter loss it
would be like 60 percent for the year
it's not going to really tell us much
because in all likelihood in the third
quarter if things go as are sort of
expected we're going to start to see a
recovery and remember that recovery in
GDP would only be a fraction of what was
lost in the second quarter the headlines
and Trump and others are going to say
for example imagine that we lose 15
percent in q2 and gain 5 percent in q3
relative to those previous numbers the
trumpet will say oh my god five percent
in a quarter we're on track for 20
percent GDP growth if you annualize it
even China doesn't grow 20 percent in a
year and of course that would be wrong
because we will have just suffered one
of the if not the greatest GDP loss in
American American history and there
would be no reason to annualize third
quarter GDP growth if we have it given
that it is a year with massive ups and
downs so the the concern I have is that
the timing of that could be very very
pernicious we are likely to learn the q3
GDP numbers at the end of October that
is days before the presidential election
and it is going to present the perfect
opportunity for Donald Trump to do what
will essentially be like 96 hours of
propaganda confusing people about q3 GDP
numbers to justify his reelection and
may work I'm trying to stay ahead of it
I don't want you to fall for the garbage
math and the reason why it's important
to understand is that this is one well
there's a couple different things first
of all you don't want to get tricked by
bad math we all want to have basic math
and statistics understanding but number
two policymakers are going to be using
bad data to justify the policies that
they would be advocating for anyway and
pretending like it's where the facts are
taking us when the reality is they'd be
advocating for the same policies no
matter what and they'd be advocating for
the re-election of Donald Trump no
matter what they will claim victory they
will claim mission accomplished
understand growth rates understand
percentages don't fall for the garbage
math make sure you're following me on
Twitter let me know what other fuzzy
math you were seeing for lack of a
better term and remember that you can
get the daily David Pakman show audio
podcast for free on iTunes stitcher
google play podcast all of your favorite
podcasting platforms sign up free and
get the daily podcast the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are joseph gable and patrick
carpenter thanks guys I so appreciate
your support I encourage you to grab a
membership at join pakman.com and then
stick around a few years if you do
you'll be like today's longtime
sustaining member of the day that's Josh
Jarvis who's been a member almost five
years it's incredible how time flies
grab a membership at join pakman.com
directly supporting shows that hopefully
you like otherwise maybe you're here for
the hate but I think most of you liked
the show grab a membership ok let's it's
been a couple weeks but I do want to get
to a new episode of hatred mail reminder
what is hatred mail why don't you take
some hydroxychloroquine for that trump
derangement syndrome patriot man written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom ok
so you know sometimes if people hate the
show this much maybe this just isn't the
show for you take a listen to this
week's hatred mail and see if you come
away with the same same same feeling
Cookman Pakman at it again the economy
is the people don't let this complacent
cuck Gaslight you into destroying the
only leverage you have your votes Pakman
the virus effect too much your judgment
your loud-mouthed will cost you a very
high price your demo rat venom is
mind-blowing is all quare like you
meaning [ __ ] stupid thinking only that
a demo rats are the best of the best
politicians on earth he worst and the
most corrupt channel there is on earth
meaning Park man I mean listen I just
don't think this is though this is the
show for you and that's ok and I you
know I don't I I don't know different
people's viewing habits for programs
I don't watch shows
that infuriate me I don't watch shows
that I believe to be corrupt I mean is
someone who covers bad media you know
I'm on some digests that let me know
this crazy thing happened on Fox this
crazy thing happened on Aon but I don't
spend my time watching this stuff if
it's not actually things it's not not
relevant to my work or something I want
to consume just find something else
that's my message and by the way
terrific opportunity speaking of the
YouTube channel which they say is the
most corrupt we have surpassed eight
hundred and forty three thousand YouTube
subscribers we are on the way to eight
hundred and fifty thousand hopefully
then nine hundred thousand and hopefully
then the big milestone of 1 million
YouTube subscribers stunning incredible
when we started this YouTube channel
more than a decade ago you know I think
it took like a year close to a year to
get our first thousand subscribers we
now regularly gain ten to twenty
thousand subscribers in one month and I
have only you to thank so very much
appreciated you can also take advantage
of the coupon code hate reott 42 save
40% on a membership of your choice at
join pakman.com that spelled h8 e RI OT
4 0 sign up and join pakman.com save 40%
with the coupon code okay it disgusts me
that at this stage of the game I have to
do this story today but I have to do
this story today it appears that
multiple states are pick your poison
having issues lying falsifying
distorting coronavirus testing case and
or death numbers and there is no doubt
that this is affecting our understanding
of how effectively we are dealing with
coronavirus in the United States in a
bunch of different parts and the reason
why this is just sickening is last week
I came to you and I said listen guys I
don't know why but there are some closed
States states that have been shut down
for months that are doing really no
better than some states that have
opened wouldn't it be amazing if states
really could reopen without seeing
spikes maybe that's possible except now
with all of these allegations of bogus
numbers and dishonest numbers and
suppression of numbers it becomes a lot
more difficult to know what's really
going on so here's the deal and some of
these individual components we've
already talked about in the past one
example was Georgia Georgia had reopened
really early started on I believe it was
April 24th their numbers didn't really
look too bad they used that data to
justify continuing to reopen other
states said look at what's going on in
Georgia we can justify reopening Georgia
officials now admit that they had
processing errors processing errors
which made it look like infections were
declining when they actually were not
that data that three times had so-called
errors was what they used to justify
reopening more and more and more when in
reality the numbers were far worse than
they were publicizing that's Georgia
Florida Florida I already told you about
the situation where cause of death was
being suppressed for a while which was
artificially holding down coronavirus
deaths I told you last week about this
data model or sort of tech person who
was pushed out / fired we still don't
have the full explanation after she said
I'm not going to falsify data which was
what she was allegedly told to do that's
Florida Arizona Arizona has become one
of the most open States and they have
also become one of the fastest spiking
states on a percentage basis they cut
off a team of Health Service experts who
were modeling the state data it wasn't
looking great instead Arizona decided
the governor Republican governor said
hey you know what let's use the federal
government modeling data which of course
is much more optimistic and much more
easily usable to justify reopening
although it is not reflective of what is
actually going on in Arizona then we
have this other story where the CDC and
11 different states have been sometimes
combining when they report tests
they're combining infection and antibody
tests which dramatically increases the
testing rate on paper reduces the
positive rate on paper it doesn't
actually reflect how many people are
catching the virus and how many active
infections there are it's absolutely
insane that this has been done and this
includes Colorado Delaware Georgia Maine
Mississippi Missouri New Hampshire
Pennsylvania Texas Vermont and Virginia
all mixing infection and antibody tests
at one point in their reporting some of
the states have since fixed this that
includes places like Vermont and
Virginia unclear which other states have
fixed this in which other states
continue to do this when we have a
situation like in Pennsylvania we are
also dramatically under counting what
the severity of the widespread infection
is because Pennsylvania is not providing
full data on cases and deaths from
nursing homes nursing homes nationally
have been huge hotspots of infection in
Massachusetts at one point 50 or 60
percent of the deaths were in nursing
homes
imagine if Massachusetts said yeah we'll
report data except from nursing homes
you'd think the outbreak was only half
as bad Nebraska at one point told meat
packing plants you don't have to report
your cases and the governor wrote it off
and said well that's a business decision
now it's a public health decision and
it's one that is propagandizing the
premature opening of states so we've
sunk lower than low we are doing in bits
and pieces what Trump slams China for
doing not telling the truth about cases
and deaths and it's happening right here
all Americans should be outraged period
this borders China aside this borders on
the totalitarian type rewriting a
reality type nonsense that we claim to
be opposed to we now simply cannot
really believe that we are doing better
or that some states are doing better
because we're not getting accurate
information it is being suppressed to
justify reopening in many states how
dare we say how dare China cover-up
the numbers when we're doing the exact
same thing and they do not care we
continue to see protests without masks
we continue to see a lack of social
distancing we continue to see full bars
and restaurants often immediately within
30 minutes of States lifting some
elements of the stay at home orders this
is a time where you know listen
Massachusetts has not been perfect
there's no doubt Charlie Baker was not
the fastest but he was much faster than
a lot of other states this is a place
where you know when I look at the data
here in Massachusetts number one I can
reasonably trust the data there is
transparency about nursing home deaths
there's transparency about testing
numbers the curve looks good we have now
been under a hundred deaths for a whole
bunch of days or you know 95 percent of
a whole bunch of days the curve is
reversing testing is being ramped up
this is one of those times where I am
genuinely glad to live in a state but is
at least somewhat tethered to truth and
reality it's not been perfect it's
certainly not been perfect but what is
happening in some of these states is
borderline criminal in the sense that it
is distorting it is public information
of govern state government releasing
information that is wrong to justify
policies and actions that lead to more
people in the hospital more people in
ICUs and more people dying and you know
all of these dishonest players Trump at
the top but people at the state level
people at local levels they all must
suffer the consequences for their
participation in this we're going to
keep covering this on Instagram at David
Pakman show I did something funny I
posted a picture of me pre quarantine
and now to my Instagram David Pakman I
barely recognized pre quarantine me it's
shocking how much my physical appearance
has changed during the quarantine
check it out at David Pakman we'll take
a quick break and we have so much more
coming up for
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on your support and the easiest way is
through membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show it's great to
welcome to the program today Anna
Muldoon who is a former science policy
adviser at the Department of Health and
Human Services currently a PhD student
at Arizona State University studying
infectious disease and social crisis so
great to talk to you today so I recently
read an article by a Turkish author I
actually forget their name but it talked
about some of the social similarities
that have taken place as infectious
disease has spread in different times in
in sort of moderately recent human
history that denial is often an initial
reaction from places outside the initial
sort of perceived source that
scapegoating is very common finding some
initial group or country or whatever
right now there's a lot of talk of China
Jews were blamed for the plague in times
past etc etc and also the idea sort of
of the disease as a personal failing a
human failing of some kind which can
take some different forms maybe we can
start there like what are the general
trends that you have studied and seen
over time related to infectious disease
so you nailed a lot of them they're
actually you know diseases a personal
failing
is a really old conception and disease
as punishment is a really old concept it
we've had that embedded in particularly
Western Christian culture for a very
very long time going all the way back to
the Bible plagues plagues and Pharaoh
but also all through European history as
infectious disease appeared and
disappeared there were moments where it
was viewed as punishment from God for
social sins punishment of the individual
for individual sins and as we moved into
a sort of more secular moment that has
transformed really in the nineteenth and
twentieth centuries into sort of
individual punishment for some
behavioral failing whatever that might
be so sometimes it is you know drinking
or partying too much cholera 19th
century caller was blamed on European
immigrants who were sort of a bit more
lively than their counterparts in New
York City and then were blamed for
having cholera saying it was spread
either by beer or occasionally by
communion wine that one was interesting
and then sort of as infectious disease
has spread this time we've seen a lot of
people talking about New Orleans and you
know Mardi Gras being the spot that
spread it through New Orleans because
those people needed to party which is
not really totally fair to New Orleans
and it's it's still very present I think
in the ways that we talk about kovat and
the ways that we have talked about
disease spread now and really for the
past several thousand years
unfortunately the idea not just of the
disease as punishment for sin but of
Prayer maybe as a protector how far back
does that go I mean we recently saw this
video of a woman leaving
megachurch where she said she's covered
in the blood of Jesus so she's fine and
so on and so forth that I'm guessing
that's also not new know also not new
very much not new it's what's
interesting is that it it the ways that
that worked kind of pre-reformation are
a little bit different and it was more
kind of prayer covering the whole
community but also a sort of acceptance
that disease was part of life now and in
particular in the United States there
have been fights about national prayer
to combat epidemics all the way back to
the 18th century right in 1721 the there
was a large smallpox outbreak in Boston
and there are fights about prayer and
predestination as they begin to
introduce inoculation and whether you
should simply pray that you survive
because if you're a good person you'll
survive or whether you should take this
inoculation which at that moment was
viewed as possibly you know violating
predestination by messing with the plan
and then in the 1830s and 1850s with
cholera on the east coast of the United
States there are some impressively
intense fights about national prayer to
prevent the epidemic that in some cases
actually threatened to unseat a variety
of politicians and turn into political
issues as well as religious issues so
that one's old and very embedded in
American culture so for me this is a
part of at least right now seeing the
current administration's handling of the
virus at least over the last month
really as a cultural war rather than a
medical war and I did a segment about
this earlier this week my perspective is
that they've essentially failed on the
medical war so they're making it about
culture and values which are much more
pliable in terms of empirically
determining what
that's going on and so masks have become
a signal of your perspective of as to
what's going on open versus closed has
become an issue of government tyranny
and so on and so forth is this the way
this often goes where it becomes a
culture war hmm
you know honestly having studied a lot
of disease history I would say that this
kind of polarization of responding to
disease is fairly unusual the fights so
the fights around infectious disease do
often fall on cultural lines right so
there's there's an author I love called
de certeau who talks about the ways that
in that in certain moments the things
that underlie society the detentions
that are already there kind of break
apart and come to light he talks about
these tensions that exist that we all
live inside sort of rising up from under
the streets it's a beautiful passage but
I think the commonality among infectious
disease outbreaks is that they intensify
and make very visible social decision
social divisions social tensions and
existing problems but rarely do you see
this kind of pretending that a disease
just doesn't exist in communities where
it does it's I obviously am studying
this as I'm working on it because it's
both fascinating and a little disturbing
- what do you attribute it I mean why
why it seems too simplistic to say well
it's because of Trump I mean he seems to
be the one who is at the top of the
federal government right now but there's
some element of society allowing that to
take place as well right absolutely I
think that America for a long time has
deeply divided along urban and rural
lines and that has very much played out
in kovat where the early outbreaks were
very much in urban areas where people
travel more and it's only now that
they're really moving into rural areas
so for a long time
the pattern of kovat in the country
actually exemplified that division
I think the America has for a long time
had some intense class division among
types of workers and that is also very
much playing out here where a lot of the
a lot of workers simply can't stay home
and so for those who can responding to
the disease is a different type of ask
right asking me to work from home on
history historical stuff or policy is a
very different ask than asking that of
someone who works in a factory we're
working from home isn't an option so
some of it I think is also about the
ways people have to justify their own
need to you know eat and continue
working and feed their families and then
some of it is the intense polarization
that we've experienced over really the
past ten years I think the divisions in
what news we watch what radio shows we
listen to what newspapers we read have
really made it possible for there to be
multiple worlds based on the same
information in a way that just hasn't
historically always been true when it
comes to talking now about stigma of
disease itself there's certain diseases
that have more social stigma attached to
them so certainly sexually transmitted
infections and diseases would be one
category within cancer lung cancer
sometimes generates less sympathy
because it can be connected to the bad
act of smoking cigarettes as an example
where does the we're
these types of pandemics that like
coronavirus kind of fit into the stigma
analysis so I wish I wish dearly that I
could tell you that pandemic disease was
an exemption from stigma
unfortunately I get I don't get to say
that so it's lower on the scale then
things like STDs or lung cancer higher
on the scale than zero so we are
starting to see problems where people
have recovered from covin and are having
difficulty still getting ambulances to
come to their house or their neighbors
don't want them to leave the house or
want them to move out of the
neighborhoods businesses where the owner
has recovered where no one will go
inside because they're afraid of the
virus and I think that that is something
we will probably see expanding there has
also unfortunately been a lot of
racialization of this virus that has
caused serious problems in a lot of
Chinese American communities but also
unfortunately other Asian American
communities that isn't so much disease
stigma as disease blame and kind of
racialization of the disease so I think
that those are those are things that we
as a society and as a nation need to
consciously combat and pay attention to
you because know someone that were
covered from kovat four months ago is
not going to give you the virus but
people are still afraid it's um one of
the ways where the stigma is is entering
a little more is with some of the
reports that for example of the younger
people that are dying overwhelmingly
they are obese and obesity is often
associated with you know moral failings
rather than medical condition so it
seems maybe that's one way in which it's
creeping in lately oh yeah I actually
started my curve the first year and a
half I was in public health I was doing
research on obesity stigma
um I found infectious disease to be a
less depressing topic and tells you
think about how bad it is yeah I think
that absolutely a lot of the things
about pre-existing conditions are
allowing people to blame those who died
of kovat for their own deaths which is
deeply frustrating you know most of the
most of the pre-existing conditions that
really predispose people to dying from
covet are those that are really
frequently linked to structural factors
in economics in race in access to
medical care in location and so it is
kind of quadruply frustrating to then
watch them become a way to write-off
Cova deaths because they're almost
entirely structurally linked
comorbidities I guess is the best way to
put it yeah no question about that and
that's often missing from you know the
science science can tell us a lot of the
facts but it doesn't it rarely tells us
about the economic and sociological
factors that kind of led to those being
being the facts we've been speaking with
animal Doon who's a former science
policy advisor at the Department of
Health and Human Services Anna so great
to speak to you I really appreciate your
time
first the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
so Twitter for the first time has
flagged Trump tweets as possibly
misleading essentially a flag they've
established a signal fake news and
Donald Trump has absolutely lost his
mind and is talking even about shutting
down social media platforms that do this
now I told you yesterday that Twitter
they kind of have special rules for
politicians and prominent figures where
normally for example you would not be
allowed to accuse random people of
murder on Twitter and SiC your followers
on them but Donald Trump did that to Joe
Scarborough and Twitter allows it
because they say when Trump does it it
in and of itself is newsworthy and thus
it should be allowed to stay because it
is the a catalyst for much reporting
it's newsworthy in in and of itself
because of the person who is doing it
so yesterday Donald Trump sent out two
tweets with absolute lies about
vote-by-mail and Twitter flagged them
both and provided fact-checking and
Donald Trump lost his you-know-what and
this is a technique that Twitter put in
place similar to one that Facebook has
when fake news articles are posted and
this is infuriating to Trump let's check
out the claims and then the truth and
this is so important not just because
good for Twitter for fact-checking the
president but it's important because
vote-by-mail is again becoming sort of
like the new battle line in the upcoming
20/20 election Donald Trump said there
is no way zero that mail-in ballots will
be anything less than substantially
fraudulent mail boxes will be robbed
ballots will be forged and even
illegally printed out and fraudulently
signed the government of California the
governor of California is sending
ballots to millions of people anyone
living in the state no matter who they
are or how they got there we'll get one
that will be followed up with
professionals telling all of these
people many of whom have never even
thought of voting before how and for
whom to vote this will be a rigged
election no way now as you can see if
you're looking at this there's a flag
there with an exclamation point that
says get the facts about mail-in ballots
sort of an instant fact check which
tells you if you click it that Donald
Trump is falsely claiming that mail and
would lead to a rigged election that's
not true there's no evidence that
mail-in ballots are linked to voter
fraud Trump falsely claims California is
going to send mail-in ballots to anyone
no matter how they got there implying
undocumented immigrants would get
ballots in fact not only is that not
true only registered voters would
receive ballots if you live in
California but are not registered to
vote you won't get a ballot at all five
states have already voted entirely by
mail all states offer some kind of
absentee voting according to NBC News
also part of the fact check
now the right-wingers who love to cry
about anti conservative discrimination
on Twitter and Facebook
they are slamming Twitter for this but
this is exactly what Twitter needs to be
doing CNN and MSNBC and Fox News should
be doing it during Trump and Caylee mag
and Annie's press briefings I've talked
about responsible platforming instant
fact-checking this is how Donald Trump's
tweets should also be handled now the
amazing thing is when Twitter did this
Trump tweeted an apology for spreading
fake news Trump deleted his tweets and
he thanked Twitter for correcting him no
obviously that's not true Trump
absolutely lost it when Twitter did this
attacking them and CNN and the
Washington Post for some reason tweeting
quote Twitter is now interfering in the
twenty20 presidential election they're
saying my statement on mail-in ballots
which will lead to massive corruption
and fraud is incorrect
based on fact-checking by fake news CNN
and the Amazon Washington Post adding
that quote Twitter is completely
stifling free speech and I as president
will not allow it to happen then Trump
actually tweeting about shutting
platforms down tweeting quote
Republicans feel that social media
platforms totally silenced conservatives
voices we will strongly regulate or
close them down before we can ever allow
this to happen
we saw what they attempted to do and
failed in 2016 we can't let a more
sophisticated version of that happen
again just like we can't let large-scale
mail-in ballots take root in our country
it would be a free-for-all on cheating
forgery and the theft of ballots whoever
cheated the most would win likewise
social media clean up your act now
extremely dangerous dystopian
totalitarian language from the president
we cannot relent on this I implore
Twitter not to relent
I implore other platforms and media
outlets on TV to do the exact same thing
instant fact-checking of Donald Trump
what would be amazing would be if
Twitter fact-checked Trump's attack on
Twitter right like is interference in
the elections inclusive of just
fact-checking the president no that's a
lie our Trump's claims about massive
corruption and fraud incorrect yes those
are not true
is fact-checking by CNN incorrect no
Trump is wrong now it should be
mentioned this is the president saying
Twitter doing fact checks has something
to do with the Constitution's first
amendment Trump is accusing Twitter of
violating his First Amendment rights can
you imagine can you imagine a president
this incompetent when it comes to the
basics of what the First Amendment is
Twitter has the same First Amendment
right to decide which falsehoods and
lies they will allow to spread on their
private platform just like other private
businesses have the ability and right to
do this was a big topic when I was on
with Joe Rogan on Friday
what should the limits be here whose
rights extend how far when it comes to
what Twitter can be compelled to do
versus what Twitter is allowed to do as
an organization that has terms and
conditions Trump is going to put huge
pressure on Twitter and other platforms
it is very clear this is part of the
culture war this is part of the battle
lines now I want this to escalate
Twitter actually could get Trump to
completely lose his mind if they keep up
the fact-checking
we
of his tweets with accurate information
good for Twitter I'm not endorsing or
criticizing anything else about Twitter
other than this is the right thing to do
they should keep doing it look at how
instantly triggered Donald Trump was
will follow what will certainly be a
wild next 24 to 48 hours as the fallout
from this continues keep an eye out one
other warning and then I want to move on
keep an eye out for how people around
Trump are going to create specious
special pleadings to argue that Twitter
should be banned from doing this
essentially we'll follow up on that when
it happens let's give it time to develop
okay Donald Trump's press secretary
Kayleigh mcenany visibly and audibly
failed to explain why Donald Trump is
accusing TV host joe scarborough of
murder on twitter during a press
briefing yesterday this was I believe
her shortest press briefing in a long
time I think it was 16 minutes only she
barely takes questions and often just
aborts when it gets a little bit dicey
and you have to see this to believe it
so to catch you up yesterday I told you
that Donald Trump spent the weekend as
the United States coronavirus death toll
approached and has now surpassed 100,000
Trump spent the weekend not just golfing
but also retweeting that Hillary Clinton
is a skank and accusing MSNBC host joe
scarborough of murder i showed you these
tweets yesterday we'll go over them one
more time Trump tweeting quote a lot of
interest in this story about psycho Joe
Scarborough so a young marathon runner
just happened to faint in his office hit
her head on his desk and died I would
think there is a lot more to this story
than that an affair what about the
so-called investigator read story
referring to a three year old right wing
nut story Trump also tweeting a blow to
her head body found under his desk
left-congress suddenly big topic of
discussion in Florida he's a nut job
with bad ratings keep digging use
forensic geniuses and as I told you
yesterday what this all relates to is a
Scarborough staffer
that tragically died in 2001 the woman
was 28 year old Lori kiss loudest
clipless Udhas maybe better better
pronounced and of course Kaylee Mackin
Annie was asked about this and the
nearly 2 minute answer that she gives is
bizarre it's a combination of what about
ISM condescension incompetence and lies
let's look at it together and I
apologize for subjecting you to a little
more than 90 seconds of this but I think
it is important to understand the full
answer that she gave or not answer that
she gave accusing somebody of possibly
murder the family is pleading with the
president to please stop conspiracy
theories doing well you know I would
note that the president said this
morning that this is not an original
Trump thought on and it is not in fact
2003 on Don Imus show it was Don Imus
and joe scarborough that joked about
killing an intern joked and laughed
about it so I that was I'm sure pretty
hurtful to Laura's family and joe
scarborough himself brought this up with
Don Imus and Joe Scarborough himself and
he's accusing somebody of possibly
murder this is different he's he's not a
private citizen he's the president and
Joe Scarborough if we want to start
talking about false accusations we have
quite a few we can go through about mica
asserting time to you and saying this
morning as recently I believe was this
morning or yesterday mica accused the
president of being responsible for a
hundred thousand deaths in this country
that's incredibly irresponsible
they've dragged his family through the
mud they've made false accusations that
I won't go through that I would not say
from this podium against the President
of the United States and they should be
held to account for their falsehoods Joe
Scarborough should be held to account
for saying people will die by taking
hydroxychloroquine never mind the
millions of Americans and people across
the world who take it for rheumatory
arthritis and other reasons there are a
litany of false headlines like Nica
spreading a false
conspiracy theory the securities acts
possible for murder I would point you
back to Joe Scarborough who laughed and
joked about this item on Don Imus to
show it's Joe Scarborough the hats to
answer these questions why is the
president doing this was the question
why is the president accusing someone of
murder and the family of the of the
victim is saying please stop Caylee
Mackin Annie's answer is Trump didn't
come up with the idea that Scarborough
murdered someone and Joe Scarborough and
Don Imus joked about murdering an intern
once now joking about murdering an
intern might be in bad taste
but it had nothing to do with this
actual death to say Trump is justified
in tweeting that maybe Joe Scarborough
killed Lori qey slaughter
with Joe Scarborough and Don Imus joking
maybe in poor taste about killing an
intern secondly Joe Scarborough and Don
Imus were not the presidents of the
United States they weren't President of
the United States tweeting bogus death
accusations bogus killing allegations to
their eighty million followers which is
what Donald Trump is doing then she says
well joe scarborough's co-host mika
brzezinski once said things we believe
to be false about Donald Trump
Mika Brzezinski is not the president
Donald Trump is the president there is
no relevance or comparison now in terms
of hydroxychloroquine people have died
from taking it but again that has
nothing to do with Trump accusing people
of murder on Twitter we're a joke guys I
hate to say it but were a joke we have a
petulant incompetent child as the
president tweeting conspiratorial murder
allegations against the TV host that he
simply doesn't like the president is
accusing people of murder on Twitter the
press secretary is defending it by
saying well other people said things we
don't like that's the defense but we're
talking about the president she has
nothing to say in reality because there
is nothing to say she represents nothing
she is the spokeswoman for a madman and
she doesn't care how does she sleep at
night she claims to be some kind of
supposed Christian that's probably a
story for another day
but absolutely unconscionable what Trump
is doing how Kaley Magnani is defending
it and the complete lack of Donald Trump
ever I mean he you know earlier I
jokingly said Trump apologized for
tweeting fake news
he just never he doesn't take
responsibility for anything he doesn't
take responsibility for the unnecessary
coronavirus deaths which are not the
full hundred thousand of course right I
mean but but some fraction certainly
would have been avoided up to sixty
percent according to a recent study had
Trump acted earlier he doesn't take
responsibility for lack of testing he
doesn't just say you know what it was
over the line to go after Joe
Scarborough in this unfounded way it did
bring unnecessary pain to the family of
the victim Lori Kislev he will never do
it he will never do it and if you're
holding your breath waiting for him to
do it you will soon die from from
asphyxiation because he's simply not
going to do it we have a voicemail
number the number is two one nine two
David P I kind of like this question
because it's a straightforward question
about the November election yeah David
this is Michael from Monroeville Indiana
and I just wanna know how likely is it
trouble with 2020 election yeah I mean
listen okay I love it's a simple
question there is no answer to this so
so when I talk about polling and a lot
of the polling looks good for Joe Biden
right now doesn't tell us what's going
to happen in November
ultimately November is going to be a
referendum on Trump specifically with
regard to the state of the economy in
the aftermath of coronavirus and it and
it may not actually be the aftermath
right we may be in a continued very long
first wave we may be in a second wave in
November I don't know but ultimately we
don't know Trump very well could get
himself reelected if the perception is
coronavirus is gone at least for now in
late October early November if Trump can
propagandize the q3 GDP numbers as I
suggested earlier today that he will if
Trump can say whoa look at this start of
a recovery beautiful
EP numbers in q3 ignoring the disaster
that was q2 he can get himself reelected
for sure and if it's close it's much
better for Donald Trump to get pushed
over the edge in just a couple of states
the way he was in 2016 with Hillary
Clinton so my message is look at the
polls from an educational perspective
and make sure that no matter what the
polls say no matter what state you live
in you recognize that you must vote we
all must vote or we are going to be
dealing with another four years of this
insanity I hope you'll join me on the
bonus show today we will talk about
what's going on with the in-person
Republican National Convention we will
talk about insulin and the president's
recent focus on it we will talk about
Republicans suing to stop the move to
allow remote votes in the House of
Representative something that would be
great to put in place all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
on my website or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video